[Music]
the new borat sequel once again pits
sasha baron cohen
in character against real americans with
controversial views
and shocking provocative and hilarious
comedy ensues
here's everything there is to know about
borat subsequent movie film because
borat subsequent movie film was made so
quickly
and under a veil of secrecy the
project's existence was something of a
surprise
amazon announced in september 2020 that
the film which had finished
shooting only weeks earlier would be
available for streaming a month later
this belies the fact that a sequel to
the original borat film took
years and a few false starts to get off
the ground at a conference in february
2007
rupert murdoch the chief executive of
the company that owned borat distributor
20th century fox
announced that sasha baron cohen had
signed on to make borat
2. that project was essentially declared
dead in 2007 when cohen told the daily
telegraph that he was retiring two of
his best known characters
ali g and borat as cohen told variety
when i was being ali g and borat i was
in character sometimes
14 hours a day and i came to love them
so admitting i am never going to play
them again
is quite a sad thing cohen went on to
other roles in other things
such as the 2016 action comedy the
brothers grimsby
which cohen promoted with an appearance
and character as borat on jimmy kimmel
live
it's possible that cohen jumped at this
opportunity to re-enter borat's world
the way borat infiltrated the 2020
republican cpac conference didn't go
down in reality
exactly as portrayed in the film in
borat subsequent movie film
burat conceals his unwelcome self under
a ku klux klan robe and hood
claiming to be president trump advisor
stephen miller
then borat safely makes his way to a
bathroom where he dons an elaborate
disguise to make himself resemble a
grotesque caricature of trump
however when he emerges in full trump
regalia
he's clearly received a professional
makeup job cohen told the new york times
that he had to wait in that bathroom for
five hours until pence finally came out
on stage
in fact the trump disguise was completed
before cohen entered cpac
and this is what was really hidden under
the white robe
speaking of killing time for the sake of
comedy cohen really did quarantine in
rural washington state with trump
supporting conservatives jerry and jim
he lived with them for five whole days
in the early days of the coronavirus
pandemic lockdown
and he even enlisted his two accidental
temporary roommates help
in writing the song he'd perform at the
march for our rights rally as country
steve
borat subsequent movie film obviously
features the return of borat
but the breakout character of the 2020
comedy is tutar
borat's heretofore unknown 15 year old
daughter who lives in a barn by his
house
and becomes the nation's gift to
american vice president mike pence
subsequent movie film marks the western
film debut for 24 year old bulgarian
actor maria bakalova
who prior to portraying tutar acted in
fewer than a dozen
mostly bulgarian projects none of those
films are particularly well known to
english-speaking comedy audiences in the
us
and elsewhere but subsequent movie films
producers still
endeavored to make sure bakalova's
performance was a revelation
pre-release materials claimed that the
actress portraying tutare was named
irina
novak an imaginary actress for whom of
course no acting record
existed in reality bakalova studied at
bulgaria's national academy for theater
and film arts and beat out more than 600
other women interested in playing twotar
subsequent movie film producers put out
an open call
and bakalova sent in a videotape
auditioned in person in london
and cohen personally selected her to
play his daughter
before she can be gifted to mike pence
tootar undergoes an extensive physical
and personality makeover which includes
coming out at a traditional genteel
debutant ball in macon georgia
borat and tutar claimed to be sandra
jessica parker drummond
and professor philip drummond iii and
stir things up with a provocative
daddy-daughter dance whose humor relies
heavily on menstruation
and prodding the fathers of some of the
other debutants to say wildly
inappropriate things about young women
subsequent movie film is presented in a
way that viewers would believe
cohen and bakalova crashed a cotillion
but the production actually created the
event
filmmakers rented out the hay house in
macon in february 2020
telling venue staff that they were
making a coming-of-age documentary
and then hired local fathers and
daughters 50 each to be extras
and take part in what was staged to look
like a real debutante ball
however once the shoot got too risque
hay house staff reportedly ended filming
prematurely
and kicked out the whole movie film cast
and crew according to wmaz
borat's subsequent movie films debut
took the world by surprise
but sasha baron cohen left clues around
the united states months before the film
hit amazon
in february 2020 abc news reported that
a donald trump impersonator
interrupted a speech by vice president
mike pence at the conservative political
action conference in maryland
security escorted the screaming foe
trump from the premises of the gaylord
national resort and convention center
and sought the assistance of the local
prince george's county police department
but no criminal charges were filed
against the well-disguised interloper
in july 2020 page six reported that
former new york city mayor rudolph
giuliani called police
over a cohen orchestrated prank
interview and the movie also proved
correct
rumors started by social media posters
who claimed to have seen the borat
character driving while being filmed
late in borat subsequent movie film the
kazakhstan government orders borat to
present his daughter tutar to rudolph
giuliani
former new york city mayor and personal
attorney to donald trump
tutar agrees to go meet with giuliani in
a hotel room
posing as a journalist but borat cannot
let his daughter debase herself
and he crashes the meeting offering
himself in place of tudar
at the exact moment cohen busts in
giuliani who up to that point has been
very handsy and flirtatious with someone
he believes to be a journalist
lays prone on a bed with his hands down
his pants
cohen chose that time for his entrance
because he grew
quote quite concerned for bakalova's
safety you're 15
she's too old for you cohen told good
morning america
it's my responsibility as a producer as
well to ensure that the lead actor is
looked after
after the scene leaked in october 2020
giuliani denied any wrongdoing
saying on his radio show i am tucking my
shirt in
i assure you that's all i was doing
then the attorney took to twitter
calling the footage quote
a complete fabrication cohen however
said it's pretty clear what
went down in a brief video as borat he
mock defended giuliani saying that the
quote
fake news media had made something out
of the
innocent sexy time encounter between a
consenting man and my 15 year old
daughter
one of the most affecting moments in
borat subsequent movie film begins with
some of the film's most audacious satire
borat proudly anti-semitic and believing
that the holocaust
didn't happen after reading a denialist
facebook page
heads to a synagogue to commit suicide
he has no money to purchase a gun so he
figures he'll just wait for the next
american mass shooting
he disguises himself as a grossly
offensive
over-the-top stereotypical idea of a
jewish person
but gets called out on his awfulness by
judith dim
evans an elderly woman who bravely
stands up to borat
and tells him the holocaust did in fact
occur
and that she bore witness to it
according to deadline sasha baron cohen
broke his own filmmaking precedent
and let evans and her companion in on
the joke
letting them know that he was making a
satirical comedy film
and that he himself is jewish subsequent
movie film distributor amazon packaged
into its x-ray bonus content
the complete telling of evan's holocaust
story and when evans died shortly after
filming
the production helped evan's family
create a memorial website
subsequent movie film is dedicated to
her memory however
evan's estate later sued the filmmakers
claiming that their late relative was
not properly informed of the nature of
the film
and that she had unwittingly helped
quote mock the holocaust
and jewish culture borat subsequent
movie film
is the second borat movie but it made
history as the first film made amidst
nationwide coronavirus caused shutdowns
within 24 hours of production companies
being cleared to start making movies
again
the necessarily small subsequent movie
film team was
out on the road gathering footage while
venturing out during a pandemic is
dangerous enough
cohen felt unsafe in other ways
according to deadline he had to wear a
bulletproof vest on at least
two separate occasions including the day
he showed up at a gun rights rally and
upset attendees
who tried to drag him out of his exit
vehicle
cohen had a big reason to complete the
movie in a timely manner
he wanted it to be released before
election day 2020.
cohen told the new york times we wanted
it to be a reminder to women
of who they were voting for or who
they're not voting for
because the coronavirus pandemic led to
the widespread closure of movie theaters
borat filmmakers had little choice but
to sign with a streaming service in
order to ensure the film reached viewers
by mid-october 2020. the winning party
who could guarantee getting it out in
time had a few reservations
regarding the film's incendiary
political content amazon
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]